brady a long count here trying to give a
hand signal to edelman takes the snap
chief spring pressure left side throw
and is broken up in the end zone broken
up in the end zone a quarter round to
edelman knocked down by rashad breland
five yards deep in the end zone the
cheats hold on downs at the five yard
line
that's chiefs radio rashad breeland got
that left arm over the top to knock the
ball away what a flop by julian edelman
though afterwards you see that yeah that
is a world-class ronaldo or lionel messi
or whoever plays soccer nowadays flop
but you do what you can to try to draw a
flag that's right it felt like the
patriots were definitely gonna score it
felt like the patriots were definitely
gonna win that's what's so amazing about
it it just had that vibe this is the
patriots and this is what we can't get
used to now the idea that after they
started ten and one for crying out loud
right with this incredible defense and
here we go number seven here it comes go
ahead and start engraving it on the
trophy not that they do they engrave it
on the trophy that's a stanley cup
anyway my point is this all of a sudden
the patriots they're in trouble they
respond to the loss of the texans with a
loss at home to the chiefs right and now
they are on to cincinnati poor bengals
next week but but
what's wrong with the patriots well i
mean the offense you know it you see it
i mean it's just you know there's not a
great run game there's not great weapons
in the pass game you know the last two
weeks two teams have figured out hey in
big situations let's stop julian edelman
let's make sure that or let's see if the
patriots can beat us with somebody else
right you know that game yesterday was
crazy from two ways to me
one the chiefs were on the border of
blowing them out at one point where
you're going whoa they're clearly the
better team on the on the field and you
know the patriots in their own patriot
way they block a punt and all of a
sudden you go whoa how is this a game
the the chiefs are totally controlled to
the point where now you go man between
the interception or the fumble by travis
kelsey that should have been not blown
and picked up for a touchdown by stefan
gilmore and then the non-touchdown you
know called nikhil harry out of bounds
at the three yard line to where you go
man the patriots could have won the game
somehow some way
i mean it really was a crazy game that
way but kudos to kansas city going into
a tough spot and playing tough and
really relying on their defense to win
the game their defense the last few
weeks has been a lot better it's why i
picked the chiefs to win the game just
throwing that out there yeah uh but no
but in all seriousness i mean you saw
what they did to the raiders last week
you know the week before that in in los
angeles city against the chargers played
well there caused turnovers played tough
uh even the tennessee titans game was
good until the you know one big run by
derrick henry in the very end of the
game where ryan tannehill to hit a few
passes but i'm encouraged by what i see
from the chiefs i actually think they're
gonna be more of a pain in the butt in
the playoffs this year just because
they're not just going to have to rely
on mahomes throwing for 400 yards and
five touchdowns they're a little more
well-rounded and they are one of only
two teams that has managed to beat the
ravens this year so right be interesting
to see if they cross paths again yeah
patriots had a 21-game home winning
streak snap wow they were booed off the
field at halftime yeah that yeah look
they're not useless
poor boston fans i know we're not going
to feel sorry someday
their teams will live up to their full
potential dominance and they can enjoy
they can enjoy the things that other
cities do like parades and just the
feeling of superiority that comes from
having great local sports franchises
right one of these days bust and just
just hang in there you'll eventually
have it uh tom brady got hit 12 times
against the tech since he got hit six
times yesterday his right arm was
wrapped up more so than normally
yesterday and you know he said it got
hit and he'll be fine and
you just wonder how many of these hits
he can take he's 42 and three it's
amazing at some point right i mean
it's when father time wins it comes
quickly and it comes suddenly and it
doesn't have to happen at the start of a
season we just assume there's going to
be a year where tom brady shows up if he
stays that long and eventually doesn't
have it anymore right there's a chance
he's going to lose it during yeah
there's a chance we are seeing him
losing it during now
nice little run from him yesterday and
great for a change it didn't look like
it was in slow motion but but the the
hits he's taking yes he's got the elbow
injury he's got the toe injury they even
right there that that throat yeah well
they throw gentlemen
yeah that was reminding me to play last
year against the steelers he's falling
away right without being hit without
without it even being close if we can
play that again and look the guy's 42
yeah and he's been as courageous as any
quarterback we've ever seen but look at
that dive no doubt how do you get what
you need to get on the ball when you are
worried about diving and falling out of
the way because you don't want to get
blown up by frank clark listen mike i
i've tried to say this on wei last week
on the radio again brady's still really
good are there a few cracks in the armor
right now with his game there definitely
is you know yeah yes i understand the
unit around him is not great and it's
probably the worst group of receivers
he's had in his career uh but he doesn't
you know he he does have to get some
some blame here a little bit yes there's
moments of him being flunchy in the
pocket and not hitting open receivers
you heard me say that a little last week
but still he's still good enough and
plays well enough to where if they had
more help around them they would be a
much better offense and they're really
struggling on that side of the ball
do you realize you threw a touchdown
pass a legit touchdown pass to kill
harry that was not
whatsoever
and how frustrating is that
yeah yeah uh i mean it's
yeah it doesn't doesn't happen very
often so
uh
you know
it happens so we still had a chance and
wish we could have scored there at the
end
reporter doing what he can to get tom
brady styling it up everyone's getting
fined there's a couple of bad calls that
happened yesterday the travis kelsey
fumbled now we've seen this before in
foxborough benefit the patriots in the
afc championship game miles jack had a
touchdown that would have put
jacksonville up 17 points in the fourth
quarter and the patriots would not have
gone to super bowl 52 in hindsight maybe
they wish they hadn't
then there is the nikhil harry touchdown
that wasn't a touchdown because and how
many times are we going to see this well
when the official is right there the
official is right there trained highly
compensated right there and misses the
this is an easy fix right and i've been
saying this from the moment that they
made
touchdowns scoring plays automatically
subject to replay review right all you
have to say for touchdowns and turnovers
yes those plays are subject to automatic
replay review plays that would have been
touchdowns or turnovers but for the
ruling on the field also should be
automatically subject to replay review
that play
why is it that it's only subject to
replay review
if he scores a touchdown right it should
be
if they got it well it'll mess up the
flow of the game like but if
it's
if he did step out of bounds and then we
stop and review it we go geez could have
been any easier
but here's the point yeah
bill belichick
had to budget his red challenge yes
that's this he didn't have one left yes
because he made a not great challenge by
challenging sammy watkins first down
catch that that shouldn't be part of the
game i don't like this whole idea of i
need to know how many of these red flags
i'm going to say i get you for possibly
getting screwed later it's the world is
a bad
hey we replay everything i don't know
what to say we don't want to get it
right or we don't i don't know then
let's go back in history and change
history too because i would like to do
that so be careful because great plays
in past history going well if we had a
replay review this way we didn't win a
dynasty so because the pottsville
maroons won a controversial game in the
20s before the invention of the
television camera we should go back and
replay it's a great example of the
pottsville maroons that's something in
the center ladies would have done better
but i i get you nonetheless just pushing
back a little bit i don't i'm surprised
you're this way captain planet just
because it's been done a certain way all
these years right we shouldn't change it
now we're changing enough we've created
a disaster by replay it's a disaster
host can i change co-hosts no you cannot
you're stuck
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports